the
recommendation to our colleagues okay in
terms of jeff how he'd been informed
sorry that he was going to be
um substantially later so he won't be
here until probably about 10 o'clock
given other commitments so
um he had made he had made me aware of
that
thank you for that sir tim thank you
nobby um as i said no public forum um
navi's informed me of uh changing his
interests
and i've got it correct uh you're a
panel member now in the regional skills
leadership group
correct and so that should be updated
are there any just on that bruce i did
send through some updates for my
interest register a few weeks ago and it
doesn't appear
right okay becks it sounds like a little
bit of admin there so
if we could uh note that please that
would be fine
are there any matters on the agenda um
that
people need to note their interests in
relationship too though
that's my court case yes that's right
and we'll have that it will have that as
the last item in public excluded so tim
so that you can
maintain maintain your distance from the
matter
so that's where we'll go so thank you so
tim for raising that
right we have we do have a monolate item
which is proposed audit fees i think
that was loaded to diligent late last
week
i do propose that rather than treat it
as a separate item we have that as part
of the
immediate item we're about to deal with
but once we've adopted the minutes
which is part of the audit new zealand
presentation on the
2021 annual
annual report audit um so
apart from that i don't think there's
any changes to the agenda other than i
might adjust my times to 11 30 rather
than 11 but
we'll see how we go
as i say help me here guys help me so
can we move to the first item please
which is
the uh the minutes for the meeting of
the 22nd of march
uh which you have in front of you um
i'll move from the chair that we
received these as a true and correct
record thank you ross
are there any matters of accuracy um or
points to note in those minutes
i don't have a person here that's big on
the apostrophes and bits and pieces
though i do want to other committees so
we
are you you are okay there's no debate
appears to be so can i put the motion
please
that we receive these minutes and adopt
them all those in favor please say aye
those against it's carried brilliant
that's great thank you
we could then move to um uh
the audit new zealand item in effect
for which it's a it's a multiple what i
would like to do
first is after michael's had a chance to
talk to this and i'd like to invite
firstly andy
to speak i would like to deal with it
that we we deal with
the consultation document and the audit
of the ltp
fest and then we will change tech and
move on to the future or the coming
order
which is the annual report so we deal
with the cd
the report that goes with that the ltp
first
then we'll worry about the annual report
thank you michael
thank you chair just to clarify am i
talking about
both reports at the same time no i'd
rather we dealt with the cd
and the the cd first and then we can
deal with the annual report please
okay so the lt ltp has gone
in in my opinion quite smoothly from
that
perspective through uh we've got to the
stage now that we have got
ordered opinion um in draft um
with your permission chair would you
like me to distribute yes have those
distributed
yeah i think it'll be useful just to see
what the
the opinion actually is it's great that
we have it from andy
uh and the the letter of representation
that goes with it as well
just why those are being circulated
these were these were received late on
friday night um
there's nothing in there that's
different from the consultations so the
letters uh the
items of emphasis have again come
through in relation to
capital delivery uh size of the size of
the capital program
and of course our external revenue so
those items were brought up as part of
the consultation
letter and there's no nothing new from
that perspective
once that's handed handed out i'll allow
people to get a copy stop waiting
right how are we going all right trisha
you're doing hard yards see you thank
you appreciate that
okay i'll take the rest of the reporters
as read
i do have rhiannon here who was the
author of the report
um just ran and had something else to
say through yourself
chair okay ryan go for it please
um i'd probably also take the report as
read
i think it's um yeah it's just a
combination of a
sorry get closer um i'll take the report
as read just to thank audit for their um
assistance through this process um it
was fairly smooth from our perspective
so i hope it was from yours
also we're just really pleased to be at
this point
um obviously that will enable us to
bring the long-term plan to council for
adoption on the 30th of june
thank you rhiannon andy would you like
to
raise any thoughts i'd be happy also to
clear out the cd management report at
the same time but obviously the key
focus
at the moment is that we have got a what
i've
put in my notes as a soft landing for 30
30 june
yeah that's fine i don't propose to talk
to the report from the cd
is there as much of a record from my
perspective of how things went
people around the table were familiar
with the themes
uh it it was a great journey and we got
there for the 20th
29th of march delighted to say over a
week from the council meetings
which is great so just to reassure you
is complete
excuse me can you just please be a wee
bit closer to speaker you are a wee bit
distant from us um and we have trouble
picking you up
okay i'll talk a bit later the speaker's
over there i'm not sure i can move quite
a while over there can you hear me now
you have that better yep that's fine
thanks andy just just to repeat i don't
propose to talk to the reporters on your
agenda that's a map of record
um from our work towards the end of
march uh just to bring you up to date as
michael already has really
the job is done the audit's complete um
assuming that is you adopt the long-term
plan
in the form that it is now um because
they'll always only complete when you
adopt it
and when you adopt the plan but you have
a letter of representation
um that they're to be signed on the 30th
of june and that's the
standard wording there are no variants
to any other
representation for any other council you
have on top of your opinions
that has three emphasis of matters just
as the cd did
so that's all confirmed and ready for
issue
so that's probably what i need to say
bruce that the job is done it's been a
been a good audit thanks to management
but for good cooperation along the way
it's been a good interaction and from my
perspective the audit has gone
from well so my last day with all the
new zealand will be the 30th of june
so my last act will be to sign the order
opinion in the cardinal city council
before
i go um when he gets adopted on the 30th
of june at three o'clock
brilliant thank you andy that's uh
tremendous news i must say what on
invercargill city this is
music to my ears it's uh this season for
audit committees and
episodes one of the smoothest with the
ltp if i can say that for
everybody's edification right are there
are there questions that folk would like
to raise perhaps if i was just to go
through it we've got the cd report it's
been taken as read
were there any questions that members
had uh from looking at that report
i only had one which was michael there
was a
comment there about the dia performance
measures
uh and the likes i'd take it that's a
meta that can be cleaned up so that we
don't have trouble when we actually come
to report on the annual report
not this year but obviously and
presumably 21 22.
yes that is correct right that's what i
wanted to hear okay
if there aren't any any questions
actually on the management report
could i then could i then just move to
the
the ltp you have in front of you the
opinion
uh as andy said you probably have been
through this in a number of
um venues in different ways
but the critical thing is it is an
unqualified opinion which is
is well done again if you go to the
second page
as or the bottom of the first page and
second page is michael said
there are emphases of matters as
uh as has been well signaled in the
situation
of uh invercargill from my reading
makes sense that's a good sign isn't it
correct we're happy there so that leaves
us then to think about the letter of
representation
because i think this should be in
addition to our uh
our resolutions is that naturally
andy requires a letter of representation
um and i think andy if i'm correct it's
standard you haven't changed anything in
this
this is the normal suite of
representations that we
as a council through
the mir make to audit new zealand as our
auditors
that we provide them with all
information etc so there's nothing
exceptional about that
but i just want to pause because we
should
um make a recommendation that the
mayor uh sign uh this letter
are there any comments on this that
people would like to make
this is the humdrum of a normal order i
hate to say it's uh it's good as long as
you're happy that's fine i've read it it
looks pretty darn good to me
no comments right oh that's tremendous
okay um uh well we'll come back to we'll
come back to dealing with the
resolutions that are related to this
uh once we have moved on to the annual
report
um but look i think um firstly uh andy
uh that probably seems wise seeing we're
sort of passing the baton now to derek
and to chris
just to acknowledge uh the points that
michael and rhiannon have made
which is our thanks to you you've been a
reasonably short tenure before your
retirement
but in that time if i can pass on my
thanks as chair
i think the relationship with audit new
zealand has solidified
um i think you've dealt with a good
number of gremlins that were probably
exhibited by both sides but particularly
by us
and it's tremendous so we do wish you
well as you uh you make the change the
break
and uh enjoy a well-earned i think
retirement is the right word but uh
whatever it is
all the best right can we can we move to
the annual report so
derek we're in your hands please uh
we'll be keen to hear what you've got to
say we have in front of us
the order the audit plan uh we also have
uh the late item which is the
fee letter which is relevant to consider
in conjunction
um with the press report and also with
uh with derek so michael trisha invite
you folk to speak first and then i'll
invite their or chris to do so patricia
thank you mr chair um so
the paper this the first attachment and
that in the paper
um is actually the report on the 2020
audit from audit new zealand
um it's outlined a number of issues
which we're going to work with
audit new zealand over the next 12
months um unfortunately we weren't able
to action any of those points
between now and then next week which
would be here end
but we have um we have managed to
on a review of them um suggest with
audit that they close a number of points
and we will report back to you when the
interim audit comes through i'm hoping
to close a number during that interim
audit
period which starts next week um
that's probably all i have to say about
the report of 2020
the 2021 audit plan and fee letter
is the other attachment fee letter being
the late
item outlines the
what i say compressed audit that we'll
have for 2021
um and the logistics is probably the
thing that you need to be aware of
the interim because of the ltp the
interim audits have been shunted till
late june we start next week
and our audit will start for council in
late september
with the view that we will adopt the
annual report on the 1st of november
which is the last date
under the statutory deadlines that we
can adopt it
so from that point and that is um
as you'll see through the logistics that
is reliant on all that hold income
the holding company and their main subs
being signed off in a timely manner as
well
so i think in prior years it's been
about the logistics
has been the key issues and um we have
now
formed a plan about how to to meet that
to meet those deadlines um
on the audit fee it's a nine percent
increase which is the maximum increase
which the officer you guys can
audit new zealand will correct me i
think it's the maximum increase that we
can receive but it's
um noted that the audit fee for
christchurch
in the cargo city is um
lower than what the office of the
auditor general would suggest for the
complexity
and so over time we'll see that increase
thank you patricia michael yes sir self
chair
uh just like to highlight on the
statutory deadline
for the annual report as well as the
timing in relation to
the w delivery of the audit
and i'm sure our our colleagues will
talk to it
but just at the moment it is very very
tight
we haven't yet had confirmation in
relation to our subsidiaries in relation
to
timing of audits um i i would hesitate
to say there's a resourcing constraint
but i will let the external auditors
talk to that
i think it's only fair that it comes
from them
okay derek we're in your hands if you
can just give us a
short briefing please thank you bruce i
think
the key issues have been identified by
management
as part of the plan as well we've
identified key risks after consultation
with management
in terms of the issues that's important
to council those have been set out in
terms of
the key risk that we will be focusing on
in terms of this audit
and some of them being the tech one
implementation
the fair value assessment of your
property planning equipment your
investment properties valuation
you've got hedge accounting and fair
value or
derivative instruments but also then
always look at management override
of intel controls as significant risk so
those are just some of the risks that
we've identified within the environment
that will be
forming part of our audit but as um
already mentioned the logistics is a key
part of the audit
and we do have a timetable within the
audit plan
but again there is a proviso that that
might change
and i think in the last couple of weeks
uh
there has been a bit more certainty in
terms of
uh as mata put it properly constraints
and and
shortages with resources um
the uh cairns the um
institute of children's accountants in
australia and new zealand
did a survey amongst the 13 biggest
accounting firms
across new zealand as well determined
that there's more than 200 auditors
short within the environment but it's
not only affecting the auditing
profession
i think with the fact that borders are
closed there's a lot of other industries
that's also struggling to get
resources to assist them within the
operations so it's affecting us as well
and due to that we now know
that we will not be able to finalize all
our audits
within the legislative time frame
currently we are engaging with the
officer forward in general in terms of
what are the possible levers that we can
utilize
to see what are the options and
alternatives
to to still get all our standards in a
reasonable time
but as soon as that's crystallized we'll
be able to communicate with council
and what the impact of that will be
um so yes timing at this point in time
uh as it's reflected in your audit plan
might change but as soon as we've got a
bit more clarity on that
we will communicate that with council
also something new that we've included
in the audit plan this year
is the materiality it also just
guides i think us as well as management
in terms of what we regard as material
because it often comes up in a lot of
discussions
uh what we regard as material on whether
that would drive a qualified
opinion or not so that i think just from
a financial
statement preparation perspective as
well as your performance information
gives more information so that we are on
the same page when
these matters are discussed
we've also implemented a new tool this
year
order dashboard which will also assist
us and management with information
sharing
it can also assist us with remote
auditing
and i think can really assist in making
the audit more efficient and
streamlined we also mentioned
the fees and that's correct yes the nine
percent increase is
uh what the auto general kept us at for
a specific year because if we were to
build the council on a full recovery
basis we were expecting
to go up to 37 increase
but again taking the environment into
account coming out of
post covert uh again there was
cognizance of that taken
and decided that an annual fee increase
will be kept at nine percent
going forward in in line to try and get
the fees to a reasonable fee
over a period of time uh you would you
would have seen
in the fee proposal letter however that
we are reflecting
the full hours that an efficient audit
will take so
currently there is a mismatch between
the hours
and the annual fee
so cheer thank you from that's maybe
just from my side
summarizing the reports that we
submitted
right so just just to make certain
that's clear
derek at the moment um the office
i'm not wanting to personalize it to you
directly but the office is not able to
guarantee the 1st of november at this
point can it
no so we're in a situation where we
haven't we have an audit plan
which actually is aspirational rather
than actually
dates to perform so the significant
matter and this is across the sector if
i can inform the committee
is that this is this is across the
sector
the issues are the auditor general is
saying on behalf of
of all his service providers that they
are not in a position at this point
to give us any confirmation about the
actual date
on which delivery will occur
okay well not okay that's the that is
the immediate situation
is there a sense there when you will be
able to give us
give us the date
yeah i think within the next two to
three weeks we would have more clarity
of what our way forward is so as soon as
uh we've got more information we'll be
able to share that with council in terms
of approach we will be taking
uh sector-wide as council might know
we've got a prioritization framework
uh in terms of which we're working uh
whereby
the financial statements of government
as an example
is first on that priority list so all
our resources
will be going towards auditing that
entity
and any entity that fits into
into the consolidated financial
statements of government similarly
um any entity that's uh traded on
the market uh financial market and got
instruments on the
financial markets authority um are also
a high priority
so you know those resources will be
going to those organizations first to
get their
audits done we do have a plan in terms
of looking at a sector for sector but
also
from priority level and it just depends
um how our resources pan out in terms of
auditing of those entities and then
what other viewers we've got available
to look at
doing the other entities right can i
open up the questions to
to members at this point please yes
ringing um
my question is around cctos
and how their their order fits in
with ours noting that eil would have had
a financial year that finished
into march so is that all on time
and i think that their fees are
completely separate
yeah michael or patricia can i ask
somebody to answer that please um i
understand that eil's audit is
on time um they have actually till the
end of this month
three months from the balance date of
march to have this signed off
so yeah and their fees are totally
separate this is just
the fee for icc
and you indicated that assuming a one
november sign off the logistics with
ichl etc has
got delivery as well yeah the risk will
be that some of our smaller
ccos will not have had their audits
completed
so normally they would be going first in
the next week or so
um that's not going to be the case this
year so
it may be that typically you would have
all the subsidiaries
audited before you would consolidate we
may this year
consolidate unaudited subsidiaries
and that would be accepted on the basis
that they're actually not material
admittedly to the overall group result
yeah the only ones we really are
concerned about would be the ichl group
yeah yeah okay and so at this stage we
have we have back to back
in the sense arrangements that they will
be their accounts will be prepared and
audited so that you've got time to
consolidate
into the group accounts that's the plan
that's the plan i give my point
i get the point patricia i get that
that's fine okay thank you for that
ringing is there any other question
people would like to raise here
is that you know um i've got several
on page 30 of the appendix one to the
tab five it refers at the bottom of the
page to
a recommendation by audit that has
applied in the last financial
review as well around treating um
treatment of subsidiaries and to ensure
there's a uniformity across the board so
i'm sort of wondering why we've got that
two years in a row without either
responding to it or
or reacting to it if somebody can help
me with that
so this is about the accounting
treatments nobby sure yeah
yeah down the road on page 30 of our
agenda yep
yeah so this is out of the management
report
so i would have thought that if if we
had an audit recommendation that
we didn't find suitable or timely that
we would make a declaration on that
it seems odd that it's come up two years
in a row
michael patricia can you help us here
please well um
this and i think i'll ask the audit
being new i also asked um audit new
zealand to comment on this one this is
on the consolidation as subsidiaries are
running different accounting policies
and actually different suite of
accounting policies than what council is
and it's the interpretation of how much
needs to be
converted back into obsessed pbe
obsessed so public sector accounting
standards
from their for-profit accounting
standards
and that is one of the things we're i
think on page 31.
we've got a management comment that we
are going to do a high-level review as
part of the
um preparation consolidation to identify
those differences
thank you patricia lovely you raised a
point which is
of um keen concern for me that going
forward we do
operate as the as the parent of the
group which would mean we would
we would have group accounting policies
we would have a group view of
of accountability and also um of the
order process
as well which this is probably the
foundational part to it
so what it means is that for the 2021
year
what we we are still on the slightly
informal process but we
we will get there with the view that we
often end up with a proper group set of
policies yes
okay thank you on page 32
where there's some reference there to
audit doing a testing on sensitive
expenditure item
and it says there are a number that were
raised that were unlikely to withstand
the scrutiny of by the public
it goes on further to talk about gst and
lack of supporting documents i just want
some clarification
that's all we're dealing with or is
there now
a list of other stuff that might come
back to bite us a little bit if there is
or
where do we get to see the um i guess
the
list of expenditures that would not
stand up to public scrutiny
it's probably a fair point now because
we've actually reviewed sensitive
expenditure as we've gone through as a
committee
so i take it this is this is derek
pointing to only a few in small number
of
items is that correct
if i get onto that i think yeah it's a
small it's a small number bruce it's
just
uh the the harder coronal in a way it's
one thing to get your policies right
it's it's a different thing again to win
over the hearts of the organization
and sometimes you find examples where
the standards that are set by the
organization are met
the the details of the one or two
examples aren't in my head
but it's just reminding of the
principles really
making sure the staff are appropriately
trained and understand what they're
expected to do
a lot
but we also do a sample of such things
across the organization i think it's
a latter where we found some examples so
it's the hearts of minds within the
organization just getting people to
comply with the expectations of it
right i think so i think this would be
something mo sorry michael
thank you through yourself the chair
just in response to that question um
since i've been here at uh council we
have
taken a closer look in relation to our
sensitive expenditure
we updated our policy a lot of the
policies but been updated since this
management item was raised and we are
taking
regular reporting in relation to our
sensitive expenditure now so
things have changed from that
perspective since this
management item sure just the last
session brief is on page 34
which refers to the holidays act 2003
normal compliance and i've read that
repeated several times through the audit
report i just wanted to get some
clarification from
management i guess when they say that we
are systematically working through an
exercise to balance and
we necessarily recalculate the leave and
it talks about where people have changed
their working hours but this is a
complex piece of work i accept that
because sometimes it's not just the
working house it can
can change the holiday exact time it can
be a change of role
for arguments saying a manager might
step down to be a supervisor for i'm
saying part way through a restructuring
process
and that changes the balance of how you
calculate so all i was really wanting to
get out of that i guess was
some sort of time framing so we're not
sitting here a year from now with the
same sort of
issues being thrown up by order
probably in michael's
agree through yourself the chair i'll
have to come back on a
time frame because that's with our
people and capability team they are
actively working on it
but i haven't got a definitive time
frame from them at this point
i think bobby there's quite a number of
recommendations in here in this report
which
which i've picked up michael um
are going to be ones that actually you
know i hear your point about actually
have they been actioned
um we are in a position which
unfortunately i feel like we were in
about a year ago when
um with michael's predecessor we had a
whole list and we wondered what the
priority was
i've seen in here that actually you will
work with the auditors
there are quite a number which i suspect
you're trying to suggest you have dealt
to
um that will be important at the end of
the sort of that we actually have an
effectiveness michael i know that you've
got that in mind
um so that we can we can monitor the
actual clearance of these
um so that we don't have any repeats are
there any other questions that you had
just
just one large question given that i'm a
first-term
counselor somebody in the room or maybe
all that new zealand can help me as well
going forward with the long-term plan
and the annual plan that flows from that
one of my colleagues suggested recently
that we do have a capacity within the
system to make variations to long-term
plans as we go forward
so i've already flagged my my issues
around the museum
project and so i don't want to dwell on
that but i just want to know the
mechanism going forward so once we get
to
the 30th of june are we locked in until
we get to the next
review which is three years from now or
do we have an ability working through
that period to actually
change what we want to deliver based on
new information or whatever it tends to
be
so this is beyond my knowledge so be
helpful to know that
oh i can provide the answer but i don't
know does anybody else
do you want to have a go you're in
charge of the time yeah
yes thank you thank you for the in there
claire as well
um look nobby uh when when the ltp
is adopted that is the plan
you make decisions on it subject to your
significance and engagement policy
you can make changes to your long-term
plan
but if they cut the threshold of
significance
you are going through a consultation
process
so all plans are variable but you just
have to think about the significance of
the matter and if it's significant yep
it needs to go through a variation of
the long-term plan which will be a
consultation
okay got that thank you right can i just
see where there's any questions ross
please i need to i need to try and wrap
this up uh more comment and it's more
about just keeping
an eye on the process given the risks
around timing
and around fees um the first and i
understand the resource issue
uh for the profession and that's across
a number of industries it's not just the
accounting profession
but i understand governments a priority
and local authorities are a lower
priority i just hope that all local
authorities are treated equally and it's
not
um we're not pushed near the bottom
because we all have the same
responsibility and timeliness to sign
off on
so i'm sure we'll be keeping an eye on
that time and as we move forward the
seconds around fees last year we did
have a
substantial an increase in fees because
of the extra work around covert
um we're still having additional hours
and
additional fees so i um
you know and against my profession i've
seen some eye-watering
uh proposals from large firms around
fees
currently you know it's not all cost
recovery we've got it
we've got to be fair as a profession
looking after our clients and the fees
and they just can't
um increase to that level year on year
thank you right so just to wrap up i
just want to go through
a couple of things the the the biggest
point that we have is that at the moment
audit new zealand uh with their with the
rest of their colleagues including
privacy the colleagues can't guarantee
the dates we have in this um
so firstly i'm making the assumption
michael and patricia that you will keep
to your deadline so the dates and the
in the i think it's the 23rd of
september when you want to have draft
financials those are dates that you will
keep to
yes the problem is that if there is if
this goes back you will be
dragged back into an audit at some later
point
when you should be focused on something
or other else correct
that is always a concern because
whenever an audit is in
they naturally demand your time and i'm
not being uh
critical at all but that's just the
reality of an audit process
so um just a couple of things there are
some issues there
like the fair value assessments on
network assets
for which we're two years old so there
could be some issues there how quickly
are we dealing with those have we done
those fear value assessments
we're about to start working on those
right okay i'll be very keen firstly
that we try and front load the issues
secondly uh derek if i could just make a
request please the earliest you know can
you please
let michael know what is the dates
that you can commit to i have said to
derek
um i would rather we had a late date and
know it now and keep to it then we
get to it we have a date which is
aspirational and then two weeks out
suddenly fine it's not going to be kept
um and the other thing is which i
understand my computer you understand
that the order dashboard process
which sounds efficient and good gives us
optics on where things are at i take it
you focus totally
okay with it brilliant okay that's
tremendous
um it'll require good humor and good
good cooperation can we please move then
to the resolutions
seems like a long time ago that we
started this item but if we can go
to and i'm still trying to find my way
around due diligence yet but i'm sure
i'll get there
right so firstly we receive the report
on the arrangements for 21 annual report
and the management report
on the 2020 annual report secondly we
received the management report
um from audit new zealand for the 2020
annual report noting the management
comments
and the issues identified and i think
we've got a discussion there that we'll
get a further report
once the next audit's out of the way and
have a plan
around the the the remote or not the
removal the dealing to the issues
and that we receive the audit
arrangements that are received from
audit new zealand and we authorize
the mirror to sign it okay so we know
the risks that are in it but we're
where's we're going to adopt it
essentially or receive it and ask the
mere to sign
do you want to move that thank you rangi
thank you
darren will be the second day i'll put
that motion all those in favor please
say aye
those against it's carrie i think i'm
going to be most embarrassed now to
recognize in fact i've also dealt with a
second item nearly
can we go to the can we go to the
long-term plan thank you claire you must
be pulling your hair out
[Laughter]
andy's already spoken to that we've
received the draft
we've received the the draft opinion
and also was received a letter of
representation
before i move the recommendations around
and there's anything that you need to
say at the stage
no nothing else right can we move the
employees to the
um uh the resolutions that we have here
first it receives a long-term plan
update um
we received the report on the
consultation document
and uh that we received and it's been
tabled obviously the opinion
and the letter we note the proposed
review process for long-term plan and i
think that's effectively the only thing
between now and then is actually we need
to meet on the 30th of june to adopt
and i think there should be a fifth item
which is that we
recommend to council and we're going to
council that the mayor
sign the letter of representation
thank you bex do i have a second thank
you rangi
i'll put that motion then although all
those motions i should say as one all
those in favor please say aye
those against it's carrie thank you very
much it's well done
thank you gentlemen and jenna appreciate
that
uh um obviously we'll be looking to look
for a bit of certainty further down the
track
but i know what you folk are betting
against as well so appreciate that
and as i said it's midway through andy
all the best man and
uh look forward to hearing what you what
you end up doing
okay if we could then please thanks guys
appreciate that
we can move on to the quarterly
financial report please that would be
great thank you
so we're looking here at the high level
issues and and and risks
um that the mayor may not be here for us
as a council as in contrast to
the work that ppp has already done
who's speaking sorry michael patricia
sorry i'm happy to speak on this one
um cheer just told i'll take the report
as read as it
um has been through the ppp committee
and we've already had
some discussions at that committee so
i'll just take the report as read
open for questions cool there are
questions from folk and i stress this is
about risky staring
no questions chair i guess just to
expedite the process i'm happy to move
that we
receive it we did note uh through the
report that we are
in the process still of of catching up
uh time frames wise
but we've been kept updated by staff uh
through that process so happy to move
that it's received
do i have a secondary thank you
vex actually are there any questions i
just wanted can i just say it i do want
to know
um uh two things one i've just noted the
the the debt position essentially the
use of cash flow
to keep the raising of debt down
and if i'm correct uh
michael there is a correction to our
interest rate cover uh required is that
right
i got that right in terms of the report
i'm just going to go over to the page
uh yeah yeah page 130 271.
there was going to be a small correction
i take it that you were talking about
making in terms of interest rate cover
um is that they're in relation to our
hedging
yes we change we made a small change in
our liability management policy which
will be adopted as part of the ltp which
takes that
potential breach of ford cover right
away
ah okay good um that's essentially the
key point
is that again from a risk perspective
we're seeing here what was it otherwise
a breach of our
of our own policies um and being
reflected here in terms of the
terms of the graph okay bring it okay
well
ross you're the other person not that
like me that hasn't seen this is
anything that you wanted to raise at the
stage
that's been nothing to add then okay in
that case let's
oh sorry uh yeah nobby um i do have a
couple of issues
just let me get to it it's a reflection
that
it's really difficult to look at some of
the figures when we got as presented to
pvp
school right across the spreadsheet
which we've put on it
mr chair very deliberately for
councillor clark who raised the matter
once before that
it was the same report that have been
presented somewhere else so we wanted to
draw it to your attention
apologies so getting it right is always
a challenge
so just two things cheer on page 110
which is the statement of comprehensive
revenue and expenditure
this signals that we've got about a 5
million
operating overspend in relation to our
revenue coming in
that's the first thing um
back two pages prior to that on page 110
we've got a net surplus of roughly five
million dollars as well
um kicking in there but that's not
revenue versus expenditure it's um
expenditure
versus forecasts and i guess i've raced
this one other time
that i find it and i've got a financial
background but i find it
sometimes a bit misleading to know where
we're going in the financial world
because um you can move around the
forecast quite nicely and it
in some way skews the figures so you
know when you look at that
page 110 and you look at the top
consolidated performance
it says we're five million dollars over
but in brackets under the june which i
can't quite read it sort of implies that
the
end of year outcome might be a half a
million dollars overspent
so that's a huge variation in one
quarter if that's a true a true movement
so
excuse my ignorance but i just um i
struggle with those sorts of figures to
know where we're going to be at the end
of the year
michael thank you through yourself the
chair um
by the i'd like to highlight both those
figures we're talking about are the
forecast figures
and we're actually um very close to
budget in relation to the actuals for
year-to-date
uh but having noted that the forecast
figure does change significantly
and a significant amount of there is the
timing in relation to collection of
rates
uh falls over into the april period um
just wanted to highlight those those two
items as part of that
yep and just one i want to raise you
through your chair is on page 109
um which is a capital expenditure by by
groups and the total of the program
has a significant underspin um and then
in light of um i guess the national
reports we're getting about our
underspend in infrastructure around
three waters
and given that we're not in winter when
you'd expect there to be less activity
than in the
other warmer months just some
understanding of why we're
significantly under 12.2 million dollars
under spent in that area
i know we can just hold that over and
over to the pmo matter when
you've got aaron in front of us here but
if we can just note that you haven't got
an answer
by that stage you might be i'm i'm open
to that question being asked thank you
are there any other questions for the
quarterly report
good point the um value of forestry
affected
in the same way it seems to be going
through the roof in terms of
uh returns
any interviews at the stage michael that
will be part of the balance uh part of
the radiation process
my presumption at 30 june that is
correct yeah
yeah okay
i think that's something that we'll have
to wait for the report from the valuers
uh satin
at this stage um but yes it's like uh
like um will be one of actually those
issues that we
want to see um makes makes its way out
early if it's possible
right there's any more questions on this
let's uh let's test the motion then that
we
should get a better go back and make
certain i've got my emotions right
essentially the received quarterly
report we do note
the forecast operating sorry 431 march
the operating deficit and
the capital program is running below
forecasters as you pointed out nobby
and we note that the the um the forecast
as outlined in the schedule
were approved as part of the ltp
deliberations i just
raise one quick question and on
page 130 um there's reference to our
our core debt being 95 million plus 43
million
which is online to the holding company
and i just want to clarify whether we
picked up an earlier meeting
that somewhere along the line maybe at
the end of the year there will be some
clarification where the
holding company will have its own debt
in its own right
and whether in fact that frees up us
with our debt level and maybe michael
can help with that
yeah thank you michael for yourself
chair uh that the final statement about
it being separate is
quite correct we've been working on that
in between
march and now and most of that is now
transferred
as per previous council resolution uh
i think it was in april so just a flow
on a quick flow question for that
um so when we look at our percentage of
that we have to apply through
the ltp and what sits with the local
government funding agency
will let that holding code debt
not be part of that when we consider
borrowing
so will it be totally separate or will
we be still
have some window of opportunity to
borrow more because we don't have to
factor in
the borrowing that we've only to the
company
through through the chair uh that is
correct in relation to the policy
just a reminder that um that any new
debt that we take on will need to be
serviced through rates so
that's the only factor you'll need to
take into account that that's okay
thank you okay so put the motion all
those in favor please say all the
motions
i'll uh all those in favor please say
aye right those against
that's carried thank you very much we
moved then on to
um uh i think it's internal audit peter
thank you
morning mr chair councillors your
worship i'll take the report as being
read just like to highlight the
following areas
areas with the internal audits we've
recently had deloitte
conduct audits of council payable cash
handling and petty cash
this involved reviewing documentation
processes
and interviewing with staffs and site
visits the findings will be discussed
with the chair of risk and assurance
with the key improvement areas will be
escalated to risk insurance as required
we've had the draft report from this and
then due to the final report
towards the end of the month
also the icc internal auditor has
conducted uh
audits and building services and
environmental services
and both these areas are on track for
the year additionally we've had one
audit
of the animal care facility against the
ministry of primary industries
dog welfare and temporary housing of
companion animal codes
this audit is ongoing and we should have
a report
to the group manager
leisure and recreation by the end of
june
thank you peter that's um that's helpful
and succinct
out of interest will the summaries of
these reports be
passed on to the committee for their
perusal yes okay brilliant
can i open it up for questions for
members i've got any yes for us
the report's fine it would be useful for
this committee to see the whole work
plan for the
internal order in its entirety um and to
just keep track of that yeah that would
be a good idea
uh and and what would be i mean i think
you've given that general sense over
some of those what it's the general
sense the number of recommendations that
are outstanding
would be good too across across them as
you as you build the program
thank you yes we'll do anything else
guys that we need to
raise here terrible interviews that word
sorry anything else members that we need
to
to raise with peter stage it not being
sorry that being the case um i'd like us
to go to the motions please which is to
receive it
and denote the internal the internal
audit and continuous
improvement updates thank you rangi do i
have a seconder thank you nobby all
those in favor please say aye
those against it's carrie thank you very
much
betty you're staying for the next item
as well yes so this chair i'll take the
report has been
read but like to highlight the sources
of risk table
the risk appetite table on page 150 of
your agenda
has been completed with results of the
council's
risk workshop we held in may you'll note
under the
risk appetite headings that we are now
using the terms
low medium high instead of adverse
balance tolerant
to make it a bit simpler to understand
additionally we conducted a comparison
between blt's risk appetite
and the councils and there was no
significant exceptions
between them
and uh finally subject to the risk
management framework being approved this
will be rolled out across the
finance and assurance group first and
this will include
risk management workshops to develop the
team's risk registers going forward
right brian thank you peter that's
useful um obviously
uh i can say obviously but it's great to
see that we're trying to
think more abrasively about
comprehensively about risk
as we start develop our risk
understanding and knowledge
do members have any questions for peter
it's porn
oh sorry nobby just just one thing um i
liked
the exercise that we did some time ago
we had a good uh workshop on us we did
um
just wanted ross advice probably more
than anything on this one um on the
bottom
in page 151 where it talks is an example
of
of the financial risk um
and you look at low and you look at
catastrophic at the absolute top
some organizations also put a um a
percentage in there as well
so for raven's sake it might be okay
let's just say for i would say
to have a million dollars lost on a
major project
but having um half that around or a
quarter that mountain a very sensitive
area um
it has a different rating so i just
wonder what your views were on there
yeah i'd agree the materiality
subset of that is important yeah
okay so maybe something for the future
yeah yeah
peter i just want to um uh i must
confess um i did enjoy by the way the
workshop and can i just
again thank the colleagues for um
participating that it was quite good
um i can i um just raise for the
community have a
personal concern on uh the
where we've landed on the risk appetite
with um health safety and well-being
only
only it's my pejorative phrase being
balanced
rather than i think i'd want to move it
to the left if i've got it right
i have a low appetite for risk in that
area
can i ask was where did elt get to with
this table in particular that matter
elt we're at um the low in for that one
was the rationale for that uh it's just
where it's really obvious
it's just where the majority landed
radio
were there others that were there others
at elt essentially you're saying
they agreed other than other than health
and safety or
governance and reputation the council
is low elt were medium
that's the only two areas of change
okay okay rodeo
um look it's it's that's useful to know
i think ultimately we want to have a
level of synchronicity between
two groups because we're the leadership
team totally of the council
is there an appetite to make changes at
this meeting or would folk like us to
take this offline
i really think health and safety is not
in the right place to be honest i've got
to be upfront about that
mr chair just you've asked a question
that you're waiting on councillors to
respond to you on
you're being asked to approve this
framework today that's right
i'm happy i'm i'm happy with the
framework i'm just i'm just worried
about table one that's fine
table one's on the framework that's
right that's right that's right
yeah knobby two things about that about
the issue you've raised i think health
and safety has a lot of legislative
requirements well-being is another issue
all again
and so pop people often roll those two
again and say oh we've got a medium
responsibility there
or risk we're in fact with health and
safety we don't have anything
but a uh low or adverse risk there we've
got no choice on that
but in the well-being that's a different
ballgame all together so
in some ways it skews it by having the
two factors in okay
i'm not going to prompt a lengthy debate
here
in terms of my falls i'm i'm more keen
that we do get the framework right
and we will need to monitor this as we
use the framework
going forward so
probably it will be i've answered my
question offline we may have another
discussion we can always bring back
changes later because actually
the framework has not the framework but
the assessments need to be dynamic
based on the based on the context with
which we are managing and governing
mr chief the only thing i would say is
that if you
adopt the framework with table one as it
is
then elt will drive a very risk-averse
approach to
governance reputation and legislative
compliance
now it would expect that you as the
governors
would be setting the reputational
matters
as much as you are able but the work
that i would be asking the officers to
do would be very focused around
legislative compliance
right so you're wanting that given we're
adopting the framework you're
you're countering my i am you that we
need to
we need to deal with this here on the
floor of the meeting yeah nobby just one
final thought um
i think we should adopt the framework
and as suggested by claire that maybe we
should have another workshop at some
stage where we engage with
eel to see their operational needs on
some of these
classifications we've done we will have
a different picture of this and our p
our view should not be the only view
there's got to be some practicality well
we do have i mean we do without making
this a workshop mobby we do have
from peter the view of the view right
some different
uh management actually where they where
they pitched which was uh
health and safety to the left and
government's reputation legislative
compliance to the right but if you
remember back in the workshop we were
floundering we really where we ended up
with a
nothing that looks like this we had a
rehash if you remember
um it was very helpful it would have
been helpful i think if we had elt here
at the same time doing
the exercise with us
or the committee rather reflected on
where the uh primary
obligation lies with respect to health
safety
obligations
that should weigh in favor of the lt's
yeah i agree the primary responsibility
lies were clear got there
absolutely okay so there goes some good
advice from lindsay about
about what lead we should follow if we
are in a quandary about where this which
would suggest needs to go to the left
thank you lindsay yeah darren can i just
clarify responsibility
or outcome because i think the
responsibility around health and safety
and actually i take on board councillor
clark's points about
wellness is it's a shame that it's been
lumped in with something that's more
legislatively prescribed
but we have our obligations um
and if we fail to meet our obligations
if the chief executive's held
responsible so yeah that's right
i think that's the point lindsay that
i've considered your your experience on
which of course is that elected members
are also officers
and they have duties obligations they
don't have the liability which is uh
their immune problems
that's right that's right agreed
mr chair that there was a program on
last night on sunday
about the injury done to
people involved in sport and
i'm just wondering if that doesn't make
us
open to the support cases
being launched at the moment
um we're dealing here particularly with
with the issue of health and safety and
employment
so this is particularly around our
obligations and
and where we want to drive risk
management in terms of
employees there is clearly also a need
to consider the public
uh in the safety of the facilities that
we we do but i'm dealing dealing here
particularly with the act
so i'm very interested to to know where
people are at
we've got a strong counterpoint here um
lindsay's points well mate clear carries
the cam
the the antenna between for her and
indeed her
leadership team is that this should be
we should have a low
risk tolerance and that she needs to
drive that
yes specs just wondering do health
safety and well-being have to be
together can we not separate
well-being out from health and safety
and therefore i guess find a middle
ground
i'll be reluctant in terms of the act
uh and i would actually question why are
we making a distinction between mental
health and physical health
yeah yeah i would support that they need
to be together because i mean you look
at
um schedule 7 part 36
local authority to be a good employer it
all covers it there
and that's that statutory um
i'd i'd be happy for it to move to the
left thank you
i've got one lobby well i would be too
because
you can imagine the scenario that we
have a fatality at work
and the buck stops with clear doesn't
stop with us as councillors that's where
it stops in our organization
and and she throws up in defense that we
had a
moderate uh approach to health and
safety in a particular area where the
accident occurred
forget the damages of all that it's just
the reputational damage as well that you
set your chief executor up to fail
[Laughter]
okay can i can i test the waters this is
not a motion but can i test waters are
we comfortable to move this to the left
i think there's enough i think there's
enough weight of evidence here to say
we've got a very strong league from elt
um there's a growing sense of unease by
me and i think one or two others that
actually we have probably and we are
probably sending the wrong signal
from a risk appetite perspective
okay so we'll move we'll move the we'll
move the
the the health safety and well-being
now to deal with clears to the left
sorry
to deal with claire's or rather elt's
view about
um governance reputation into state of
compliance and control
it's interesting um this is one which is
which is
uh i wonder whether it could be split
but that would only be my view
um legislative compliance is one thing
rep clear has focused on reputation
well i heard that and i heard that in
the comments
we have a low appetite
for reputational risk that says we will
do something quite significant about it
is that
is that where we're at
the view from elt is that this is a
moderate
risk well i guess for my governance area
i guess um
and when when you're at rock bottom as
far as your reputation is concerning the
public is
and i guess we don't want to go any
worse than that i guess
in some ways i guess the eot is saying
actually there is some scope there to
actually take a few risks
and it might backfire on you but you've
got to be a bit brave sometimes so i
guess that's the
yep any other views yes
i think and now that we have our charter
that's sitting in the left fits with the
charter
that would be my opinion because the
charter is pretty strong
about about reputation and
joint reputation right
that's good any other views so nobody's
angling to move this to the right
which is fine uh claire's indicated that
that does have some impact on the way in
which
management will be seeking to work with
us
okay so be it that's fine as i said we
can always re we
we need to revisit this as we go on but
let's see
let's see where that reflects okay um
are there any other matters on this
framework and process that people would
like to raise
peter i just want to confirm um and i
think you've said it to me which is good
which is actually it's one thing for us
to adopt this it's even one thing for
elt to have this
in the in their minds but you said you
were starting to roll this out
into the departments is that correct yes
we're going to start with the finance
insurance group first
roll it out there we'll run some
workshops um more than likely
get it outside provider to assist with
those workshops
to develop the risk registers so we can
start from the scratch and building up
that risk profile
my interest is actually we're developing
the culture within the organisation of
being
effective risk management i want to say
risk just be part of your normal
business as usual but that's effect
that's essentially what you're trying to
do there as far as that's concerned yes
brilliant okay are there any other
questions for peter all from
well probably michael or myself anybody
over over the
the risk framework
there being none can we can we go to the
resolutions then please
which is that we receive uh this and
that we
approve the framework policy and process
for introduction across
council um i think we we don't need to
note in the resolution that we've made
that one amendment
uh to table one um i think we in
adopting the sir agreeing that it's
going to be left
okay i'll move from the chair that we we
chair i'm sorry but for the purposes of
record keeping
we will note as amended uh and we will
note in the discussion paper that table
one was amended
just fine yeah that's fine that's cool
if that's
the more secure way i'm very happy to
take your advice so there'll be
there will be um a change so we approve
um uh for the introduction the the
policy framework policy and process
introduction across council with the
amendment of table one
to recognize the low risk appetite
for health safety and well-being
i'll move that from the chair to i have
a second to please
thank you rangi any discussion on the
on the motion being none i'll put all
those in favor please say
aye those against it's carrick thank you
very much
right thank you
thank you for that peter appreciate your
work it's good to get it there and it's
good to see it see it moving
right can we move to the project
management office please
thank you
you want me to start
okay i'll just step in at the start just
to talk
to um the points that were raised by
councillor clark if that's okay chair
yes go for it aaron that's great thank
you okay uh
so around our three waters program this
is
a point that we've bought into our
strategic projects so we do have a
framework around holding
pcgs reporting to the steering group and
reporting to this committee around our
three waters program
where we're at with that program is that
there is a panel of contractors in place
which we
share across our other southland
councils
that panel has probably got some things
that aren't working as well as we would
like
with it one is that
in establishing the panel the
contractors asked us
to look at design and build contracts
for that panel
when we've started letting those design
and build contact contracts what we've
found is that there's
really not the i guess technical
resource within the local market to be
able to do that
so we've had to take a different
approach where we've asked contractors
rather than doing their own design
to partner with a consulting firm and
we'll be working through the design with
that consulting firm and then the
construction
with the contractors that slowed our
program
down somewhat and is something that both
us and
sdc in particular are experiencing
the other key is just around resourcing
internally around the program so we've
got some vacancies
there which we are pushing to fill we
will have
given that we are struggling to fill
those vacancies we will have a
consulting project manager
who is starting with us this week to
assist to put some extra
muscle behind that program
and also simply that this is that area
where the construction market
is struggling to respond so we've got
plenty of work
out there with the market and timeline
slipping
we do need to look at how we bring
some more robustness into the contract
framework around those slipping
timelines as well
the final piece i'd just like to note is
because the three waters financials are
quite dispersed and across multiple
different projects
we are really struggling to be able to
get actuals reporting across our three
waters program
so if i have a look at what we've got in
terms of our pcg reporting and then i
compare that to what we've got in terms
of the financial reporting that's gone
up
there is a bit of disparity between that
quite a bit actually which we're still
working through
so i would actually suggest that the
program although not where i would like
it to be is not as bad as it's reflected
in the financials
um so for example our stormwater
delivery is probably up
just below the 50 mark not where we'd
like it to be um but we do have some
more work to do there around those
financials
thank you for that aaron it's tess isn't
it
test is there anything you'd like to add
sorry
so in terms of the pmo general um since
the last reporting period we've made
reasonably good progress in terms of
establishing the project management
office and the processes associated with
that
so across the projects in the pmo we
have pcg reporting
monthly now we have
we have a much better understanding of
the status of those projects
and some of the issues that we're
dealing with them um in terms of
um i suppose progress we've healthy
homes is well underway
so we've we've seen some some good wins
on that the market has been um
pretty respondent to that project
actually in terms of finding suppliers
to do the work
um we've also managed to we're in the
process of securing a contractor for
anderson house
um so we are looking to get into
construction on that albeit
later than what we would have liked that
lateness is simply due to availability
of contractors and that's
in that kind of lower tier 1 million to
1.5 million
range um so we are looking to go into
construction on that um
later this year uh probably the project
that
is um of of concern is the stead street
stock bank
from that project's perspective the
design has certainly been
more complicated than what was
anticipated when the project started
it's been a bit of a mixed bag just in
terms of the technical issues that the
designers have been dealing with
has certainly impacted on where the
budgets are starting to land
conversely we've had a good response
from the market in terms of specialist
sheet piling companies
physically doing the works so we've got
some challenges in terms of we've closed
out the design now it's gone out to the
market
but we are definitely behind where the
project needs to be in terms of the
funding
and the project closing out in april
2022
so we're working with the contractors
that we've issued the
rfp the request for tinders out to
making sure that they understand the
time frame we're working to as well
so they can achieve that deliverable
thank you for that test right can i open
this up to questions
not be perhaps you've got first friday
questions given you uh
you raised the questions thank you um
several issues really i guess and one of
the big issues for me that sits over and
above what i've just heard
is that where do we go in the next two
or two and a half years before the new
water entity takes over three waters
there's mixed
views around the councils across the
country about whether
whether a council would be wise to go up
into development
at a local level build up debt and
knowing that debt transfers across to
the entity that's one option
but the other option for me is that we
need i think we need to consider
is whether we um just slowly wind back a
little bit on
what we're projecting to do in three
waters given that when you look at the
otago southland
results across all the councils in that
region which matt will talk to later
today
we do work really well but we have done
well
and our financial position is very
strong in comparison to other councils
so we're well above the medium
so why do you keep pouring money in if
you're already above the medium
and if we create some surpluses here
this is services that we could use
somewhere else in our
suite of long-term plan projects so i
guess that's a
that's a balancing act for me right it's
slightly bigger than the
direct pmo question that we have in
front of us here nobby that's uh
there's a lot a lot there i don't know
whether management would have any
comment they'd like to make on that at
this stage
there's going to be a pretty sharp
pointed piece in terms of three waters
coming up and what is it august or
september
um so i don't know whether whether
that's a particular
you know time-wise it's going to be
particularly wrongy um
regarding what nobby has brought up
wouldn't we be bound though to carry on
with our
uh 30-year infrastructure plan and our
current ltp in the sense that that's
as you said an ltp is is
once you strike it you you basically do
it
unless you're going to change it so i
would assume the government would expect
every council to
stick by their plans um
really at this stage you know you can't
really
you just look there's not a big pause
button and and wait
um well like as i say i think i think we
probably we're probably struggling in
the
territory which is a little bit outside
the direct direct pmo
we have prepared the ltp i think you're
hinting at this rangi on the basis of
business as usual
that's been that's been essentially the
way the sector's taken it as a
as a whole i'm while we have an absence
of information
i am trying to hint that probably august
september
there's going to be a much stronger view
which has to be the
government shown its hand so in fact the
amount of physical work that happens
between now and then or is commissioned
is probably going to be what what our
current plan is aaron do you have a view
on that
yeah so what i'd just like to talk to is
that although invercargill city has
invested really well in its three waters
networks and should be very proud of
that
um even what we have forecast which is
an increase into next
financial year still doesn't actually
have us quite keeping up with our
renewals profiles so
as much as we're doing well we're doing
well compared to quite a low base
across the country um so just clarifying
that point
and then i think we've also got some
other forums that are coming up which
will allow us to get into
um some of the depth around those points
over the coming weeks
agreed thank you so we restricted to the
pmo issue and and the program is we have
agreed
to do it at the moment thank you if we
could that would be great uh members we
could stick to any other questions
certainly on on page 163 we've got a
dashboard report that
forecasts ahead so just a couple of
points on that
um one is we've got the water tower and
control building
um project closed and i'm not sure what
project close was because i think in the
long term plan
we kicked that out three or four years
so well that's just the we
tweak that we might need to do thank you
looks like tess you've got the answer
yeah sure we we are just closing the
design out on that project
um so the intent would be the next
reporting period for us and the pcg
and we will have that project closed out
for the next two or three years but it
will carry on obviously in the long-term
plan
all right well thank you that that
explains to me a question i had why you
stopped stop the design okay gotcha yeah
okay
yes frankie yeah just uh water tower
um the last time we saw it it was around
the 4.6
is that that's been revisited um
no it was it was between four and four
point five so now it's sitting at
approximately four million i mean it's
an estimate at this stage um
until we close out the design
documentation
and we we got those if we were to get
detailed estimates back but we're
indicating that it's sitting at about
the four million mark
and that's at 67. that is at 67
mbs yes okay thank you
thank you for that any more questions
folk yes nobby
just a reflection on on page 165
which is the program financials i see
marked in there in the
in the variations for the museum it
talks about 14 million dollars
under budget i guess i had some issue
with that and
my views are well known on this issue
but we're not factoring in
um funding that we already know is
available to us four arguments hey we've
got five million dollars
uh sitting in the in the banks at uh
community trust itself and somebody goes
down and asks them that they'll confirm
that
so that figure i guess in some ways
allows people that we're
what we're doing in a museum has a
massive shortfall but i don't think we
do have so
i'm just signaling that i guess i'm not
asking for a comment
i think you're naughty so erin just a
couple questions from me or tess
um the yellow because i noticed every
project that's got the yellow diamond
which is a medium likelihood of not
meeting the date that sort of put me in
a slightly oh this is not
looking so good um but i don't i don't
think you quite mean that
am i right um yes look there there are
challenges
across the program um we know for as for
as an example on the streetscapes
project it just takes
one issue for us to potentially have a
problem on that project
so i wouldn't feel comfortable reporting
it as it were currently tracking
to the program but we just need one
problem and then the wheels start to
fall off
i've got concerns about the contracting
market in general you know we're seeing
kind of
a wild response on the one hand with
projects that are very technically
challenging we're getting good responses
back
on smaller projects that you think the
market would be more interested in
it's taking us a long time to to kind of
entice the market to tender on them
yes um so from that perspective there
you know there's
the other issue we're dealing with is
just the resourcing within the
consulting market
in terms of being able to respond to the
turnaround time frames that we've got
for design
um so yes whilst whilst a lot of them
are most of them are showing that
there's a possibility we won't meet
program
i think that's a real possibility we're
managing it but the possibility is
definitely there
great thank you for that insight that's
that's um very helpful
and uh look you are reinforcing
as you have a key point around the
market at the moment is difficult to
work with
and so i just um suspect it's important
for us to acknowledge
the other one i just wanted to check on
was just on on page 166
and in terms of the the the projects i
think you've been quite upfront over
stead streak
yeah uh which is fine and i think we've
also discussed the museum
uh and and the rest stand there
is um the rag status on the right hand
side is read as issues
i think i've got the general sense now
thank you in terms of the totality
of it nobody you raised a good point
about about what is the response in
relation to the three waters reform but
it sounds like you i think you
as you said as even today you've got
more meetings on that which is more a
strategic decision about how you
approach impending change rather than
the
immediacy of the renewals program at the
moment
there's any other questions folk would
like to raise at this stage it's very
good report
all right nobody said i'm clear it's
just reminding me that you did raise a
couple of questions under financials if
i have i got all your questions or have
you had a chance to ask all your
questions um
no just just bit more making a statement
really about the
about the issue of the 14 million dollar
shortfall for the museum
based on the ltp which as you know i
don't agree with the what we've got in
there
um but that's okay um i just think
that's that figure of 14 million is not
an accurate okay
um the chair of the community trusted
advised me on two occasions
that when the when we when we attempted
to
do a previous museum there was five
million dollars allocated to that
project
it was subsequently withdrawn by ctos um
but they have written off their books so
it is still available there for us
so i just think somebody in our uh pmo
team
needs to get down the track and talk to
trish about that because that will
change that figure
and sorry you see that they have that
has been written off
it has been yes or no yes part of that
okay so it's there for us and we just
need to
sorry it's been unification it was
written the grant
was actually cancelled and cancelled
yeah
but what are that's not available it's
you're saying it's not available
i mean i don't know at least can i just
check on interest here but you're
obviously here
well
what trish told me was the money still
there for us
so i think i think that the conversation
is probably best
ended on the understanding that the
prior application
has been closed out and council will
need to make a new application to the
trust
which will have new financial
circumstances post-covert
correct okay darren and then rangy
it really was just to to that point
chair we can't count that money in
until we've got emotion from the
community trust confirming it yeah
okay thank you oh i was
my point's more about the comment tree
on that
14 million that knobby's talking about
um
i've always understood that that that 14
million is external funding
and if you use like rather than a gap or
whatever
um maybe the comments paint it
paint a gloomy picture and and that the
14 million there's a
there's a shortfall it's it's it's going
to be hard to get but if
if it just refers to external funding
then it sits
without anyone saying how hard or easy
it will be to get
i don't know i'm just i'm just saying
that that external funding is external
funding and of course you don't get it
until you apply for it but you've either
got to be optimistic or pessimistic
we we can make that change just to note
around it being
external funding um i do think though
that we also want to be
realistic to the point made around it
being a post-covert market
as well right thank you for that
i think we've got good clarity on that
and appreciate the words do count as
well
right can i ask that we look at the
motion please which is
that we receive the report don't be
prepared to move there please
thank you bex appreciate it have a
seconder thank you darren appreciate
that i'll put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
those against it's carrie thank you erin
and tess that's a really great report
very helpful
uh an insight for because since the risk
the market
this is the market that's what's
affecting us
right um we have uh dealt with the
late item along with um
uh along with the initial book with the
auditors
i was looking for my motion i think
that's in the other papers isn't it to
move into
um uh into public excluded
just bear with me i need to find my
other agenda please
um i thought i had the motion for we've
got a motion to move into public
included should have
it's probably good to know that we've
got some reasonable ground so i'm
reasonably comfortable that
uh these these matters are subject to
public excluded
um but can you i thought i'd see them on
page
no i appreciate you gotta list the
reasons that's what shoot over the page
okay sorry it wasn't so no i did remind
them i didn't read my minutes but i was
struggling with where they were okay i
could put the motion on the basis of the
grounds that are set out there
so on page three of our open agenda uh
my apologies for this
slight mess on my part we have a
motion um to move into public excluded
for the reasons
that we have there for the seven or
eight items that we
we have i don't propose to read them all
but you've had a chance to
uh look at them i'll move
uh from the chair that we move into
public excluded thank you darren second
set all those in favor please say aye
okay those against it's carried thank
you we'll just wait a couple of moments
while we
you